just a few weeks shy of her 100th
birthday the iconic beloved and
groundbreaking Betty White passed away
on December 31st 2021 a few days before
on December 28th the actor took to
Instagram to share her latest cover of
People magazine with fans the headline
of which read Betty White turns 100 with
a quotation reading funny never gets old
the magazine includes an exclusive
interview with the actress which was one
of White's last before her passing while
also featuring several of White's
friends including actors Ryan Reynolds
Carol Burnett and Sandra Bullock on top
of that the cover references the
legendary actors secrets for happiness
having lived for such a long time white
witnessed plenty of change in the world
including the rise of social media and
she adapted to everything with Grace her
Instagram account has 1.9 million
followers who eagerly awaited any and
all news white posted about White's
prolific portfolio of award-winning work
her efforts as an animal rights activist
and the lasting impact she had in the
world of Comedy will no doubt be
celebrated for years to come but her
final Institute gram post is causing its
fair share of heartbreak for her fans
around the world white captioned her
last Instagram post my 100th birthday I
cannot believe it is coming up and
People magazine is celebrating with me
in a matter of hours the December 28th
post garnered a large amount of likes
and comments and as one fan wrote in the
wake of the news of her death she is
forever a golden girl in our hearts the
ultimately heartbreaking post currently
sits at well over 600 000 likes and
Counting with a heartwarming comment
from one follower reading simply
National Treasure White's career spans
nearly eight decades and in that time
the five-time Emmy award-winning
Illinois native also took on the roles
of writer and producer as an actor she
brought an endless list of Unforgettable
characters to life all her character on
Golden Girl is arguably her most
well-known she also made her Mark with
performances and other projects like Hot
in Cleveland the proposal and the Mary
Tyler Moore Show in the People magazine
feature friend and co-star Sandra
Bullock who starred in The Proposal with
white said she hoped white would
celebrate her birthday the same way she
quotes celebrated every day of her life
with humor kindness and a vodka and Ice
toasting to the fact that she's a badass
who has left us all in the dust while
the occasion is now much sadder than it
should have been many people around the
world are still planning to celebrate
the life of Betty White on what would
have been her 100th birthday on January
17 2022. the plan's already in place
include a documentary movie special that
will be in theaters for one night only
called Betty White 100 years young a
short trailer for the movie distributed
by fathom events includes clips from the
Entertainer's long career as well as an
invitation from White herself telling
fans that there is only one place to get
the real Betty White and that's here in
this movie what better way to celebrate
the life of Betty White than to spend
January 17th celebrating with a woman
herself the producers of the movie Steve
betcher and Mike trinkline shared their
thoughts about the prolific actress in a
statement after her death they said
Betty always said she was the luckiest
broad on two feet to have had a career
as long as she did and honestly we were
the lucky ones to have had her for so
long clarifying their plans for the film
they stated that the movie will still
Premiere as plan to quote provide a way
for all who loved her to celebrate her
life and experience what made her such a
national treasure the movie will
highlight White's fantastic long career
including her final interview and
showcased the many friends who loved her
so much including Ryan Reynolds Carol
Burnett's Robert Redford Clint Eastwood
Valerie Bertinelli and many more